If it was bear claws,
we'd clearly call it a bear.
But because it was her husband's hand,
oh, it was accidental.
We choose bear.
Because even though statistically
we know that
divorce and leaving is the most dangerous time for a woman's life,
and even though she can journal and write,
this is exactly what's going to happen,
I promise you.
And when that exact thing happens and she is proven right,
even in her death,
she doesn't get the validation she's deserved.
Even when everything is pointing in the right direction,
we are still not believed, and we are still
getting the shit end of the stick.
Like, I don't know a fucking polite way to say it.